these three scenes all have something in
common and it's not just the fall it's
how the actors fall first forward then
right before impact twisting to land on
their back this is a technique hollywood
calls the suicide fall and it helps
stunt actors avoid spinal injuries it's
just one of many stunt jumps performers
use over and over to make scenes
action-packed while making sure no one
gets hurt here's another example of the
same fall
that's stunt performer teacher and
martial arts expert stephen kepfer he
has been using these techniques for
years in movies like john wick and tv
shows like ray donovan
you kind of want to be like a cat right
you can land however you want no matter
if you're flying through the air out of
control
we went to his new york city studio to
go over eight falls that stunt
performers use over and over in movies
and their tricks to staying safe
warning
don't try these at home
we've all witnessed bomb scenes where
everyone flies into the air
but how do actors fly dramatic distances
and heights convincingly while avoiding
whiplash and broken bones
say if it's an explosion if you're
needing to fly through the air we have
to go to aids and that's usually a wire
or a mini [ __ ] or something like that
springboards and mini trampolines can
launch them up to 30 feet in the air
while wires can propel them even further
but wires come with additional dangers
you're going to have more possibility of
a let's say a whiplash like on a wire
there is some control how fast you're
going to get pulled how high you're
going to get pulled things like that but
what's happening to you
you flying and you know you can't
control that so we're always
kind of starting from a place of control
and that only comes from experience and
time flying on a wire can also be used
during a superhero fight where someone
is thrown
it's all the same principles
the only difference is now you're doing
it at a higher velocity from a higher
elevation
so you have all these additional risk
factors to think about
this is one of the highest free falls in
movie history
stunt performer damian walters fell 125
feet for 2016's assassins creed's leap
of faith normally filmmakers would use
visual effects to create a digital
character for a fall this high
but assassin's creed used just an airbag
with no wire attached to the performer
in some cases like this scene in john
wick low falls are done to cheat the
higher falls on a green screen making it
much safer for the performer
and there's definitely more
complications or low falls because you
don't have a lot of time to adjust with
a high fault you have a lot of time to
get your position this one's pretty
quick
nice low falls are falls below 40 feet
but usually no more than 20 feet
this is still high enough to cause
serious injury
cardboard boxes or airbags are used to
stop in the landing so on an airbag you
have to land almost completely flat in
like a starfish position to avoid spine
injury in a high fall stunt performers
will usually do the suicide ball we
mentioned earlier or a header a header
also allows you to fall flat on your
back but the stunt person essentially
does a dive roll to get there
for low falls non-performers might not
use an airbag so instead we'll do what's
called toe tapping which is where you
try to tap your foot first so we don't
land everything
but first the thing is if you do that on
an airbag it'll fold you like a taco
because the airbag sucks you in so
depending on the
surface you're landing on
your you are gonna land differently
roof to roof jumps like this one in the
born ultimatum require careful planning
and execution first of all they're often
performed on real rooftops which are at
dangerous heights
and secondly the actor needs to be
moving and preparing for impact on the
other side
when a stunt performer has to do a jump
over a long distance from a roof to a
roof it's all about
landing properly just going to run
try to clear the space
do a roll just finishing control
bill you'll test it with weight with uh
weighted sandbags you'll test it how
fast can the actor run how fast can
somebody jump not on roof attempts over
10 feet are considered deadly and
performers should be protected with a
wire if i were to fall off the ledge i
would be hanging there from the wire
even though you're okay because you're
not hitting the concrete six stories
down you fall off the wire you can swing
hit the building there's lots of things
that could happen
that would not be good so one of the
things about being on a wire is you just
have to learn how to move with it be
aware of it but forget that it's there
too parkour techniques are also common
for roof to roof jumps for sprinting
leaps and rolls we can see this
throughout the opening chase scene of
casino royale when bond jumps from one
height to another
in the new boba fett series there was a
big rooftop chase right that's all
parkour stuff
when an actor is pushed injured or slips
and rolls down a flight of stairs they
need an experienced stunt person who is
trained not to get hurt
so how do performers survive the tumble
without breaking their neck or
sustaining head trauma
i would describe stair falls for me fun
and addictive but super dangerous you
have to learn how to fall to begin with
on a flat surface right and then you
start learning how to fall on a diagonal
surface and then more jagged surfaces
it's all about
understanding your own body awareness
in space stunt people typically wear
padding under their clothing and
sometimes padding is placed at the end
of the staircase but when a scene
requires us to see the final landing a
stunt person may not have that luxury
pads or not stunt actors tuck their
chins and fall into a ball-like motion
making sure to protect their head with
their arms understand how to protect
your head you don't want any concussions
not get your ankle stuck in a banister
your arm or something could get stuck
those are the biggest things
[Music]
so if you're getting shot it depends
where you're getting shot are you
getting shot in the head are you getting
shot in the shoulder in the knee
what kind of gun are you getting shot
with so all those factors come into play
and how your performance is going to
show the reaction to getting shot hey
handgun bullet falls may seem like
simple reactions to portray but falling
incorrectly can still be dangerous
there's lots of dangers hidden inside of
any kind of fall from the feet and
getting shot number one is concussions
not hitting the head anytime you start
to feel like oh this is this would be
cake let's just breeze through that
take a step back
and and look at everything again for
scenes where larger and more powerful
guns are used the effect of the blow is
stronger so stunt falls may need to
cover more distance with the help of
wires in this case stun people may
perform a dead man on a wire which
generally is used with a large gun or
when someone is running and gets shot
mid-run
a close combat scene between two or more
stunt people is usually not the same as
a regular fight
most times they will need to fall from
their feet fighters can't be too stiff
with their strikes or falls but they
need to make it more cinematic while
still being safe best performers are the
ones who can take that foundation they
have in fight skills or martial arts
learn how to make it look dirty and do
it slightly wrong for the camera
because it doesn't look good if you look
like you're doing some proper judo fall
in a show in the middle of a fight
performers tend to use a variation of
three falls the main ones are front fall
back fall
side fall
front falls are dangerous to the face
chest groin and elbows so performers
land in a plank position on the palms
first and then spread the fall from
there
back falls are safer when you land on
the upper back and feet to disperse the
energy while keeping the chin tucked to
prevent impact in the back of the head
and then side falls can cause serious
injury to the tailbone and shoulders so
it's important to lead with the arm land
palm down and use the feet to ease the
fall on the tailbone in the industry
there
probably are a lot more injuries in the
smaller gags like the pratt falls and
the falls from the feet
than the big giant high falls would take
a lot of rehearsal
falling from a moving vehicle or train
is one of the most dangerous falls on
the list for a stunt performer
you're in that out of control moment you
know and you're now going extra fast
because you're jumping off of a moving
object so all that added velocity is
what you have to really
think about stunt performers use a
variation of what's known as a dive roll
in rack they protect themselves from
impact by rotating to break the fall and
speed while maintaining the proper
posture to prevent injury
one of the things when you hit the
ground
is to be relaxed you don't want to be
the the water balloon that pops when it
hits the ground you want to be so
relaxed when you hit the ground that
you're more malleable you're not tense
you know and that helps you survive the
impact
all of these falls are used over and
over again for action movies it's on
stunt performers to have the proper
training and adapt these techniques to
whatever situation might arise
we'll have people that are professional
gymnasts dancers
acrobats and different kinds of martial
arts it's really about taking what works
from all the different things that you
know and making it all come together for
the performance
go
[Music]
dude i feel like you flew on that one i
couldn't see it but it was like that was
so good it's good
nice
awesome
all right let's let's see the playback